I don't care who you are the Time Lord
victorious is wrong oh no actually okay
that does sound pretty cool
[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks so there was an announcement
of a Doctor Who thing we don't know
exactly what it is we kind of know what
it is I want to talk through what it is
my thoughts on what we know so far a
little bit of speculation and also I'll
say emphatically what it isn't just
before anybody in my comments tries to
spin it as something so the Time Lord
victorious is some form of
multi-platform story I'm actually going
to read directly from what went up on
Doctor Who TV a very similar
announcement also went up on Big Finish
Time Lord victorious will be set within
the dark times capital D capital t at
the start of the universe when even the
Eternals were young it features the
eighth ninth and tenth doctors traveling
across space and time as they defend the
universe from a terrible race as well as
three doctors companion Rose Tyler and
monsters including the Daleks and the
OOD we'll feature plus more to be
revealed over the coming months as
products are announced partners involved
in the project include penguin Random
House BBC book star 2 magazine Tyne
comas escape hunt Big Finish and
immersive everywhere so this is a brand
new multi-platform Doctor Who story told
across audio's novels comics vinyl
digital immersive theater escape rooms
and games what so whatever this thing is
it's ambitious however conspicuous by
its absence is the mention of television
so the first thing I think we need to
assume is that for all the stuff being
involved in this this is not anything to
do with the show as it is being aired on
TV this is not a special this is not
going to impact the ongoing Whitaker
Chris Chibnall era of the show this is
independent of that which then brings us
to let's look at those names involved
the 10th doctor the 8th doctor the Ninth
Doctor and Rose Tyler
so 8th doctor 9th doctor Rose Tyler they
have been used fairly regularly in
various extra media you know novels
they've all done Big Finish I mean God
Paul McGann's doctor practically exists
almost entirely and in Big Finish and
you know David Tennant on Big Finish and
so is rose
Christopher Eccleston never has now I
they have not officially announced yet
what's gonna land where on what parts go
anywhere else so it is possible let's
let's accept this it is possible that
Christopher Eccleston himself is not
going to be involved in only the
character of the Ninth Doctor is how
does that work well some of the media
that they mentioned specifically things
like comics and novels they could use
the ninth doctor his likeness as a
character and not have to involve
Christopher Eccleston specifically as a
person in order to do so so if the ninth
doctors part in this story is covered in
novels or is covered in comics or
anything that is a medium that doesn't
require his active participation that's
possible and it will also be very
disappointing and if that is the case I
hope they clarify it soon because
otherwise I'm the longer they wait to
drop that the more I'll be disappointed
that having been said I'm inclined to
think that this means Christopher
Eccleston might be making his debut as
the 9th doctor on Big Finish in the
audio dramas for
Giroux I've been kind of holding on to
this possibility because before
everything went to hell I went to the
Gallifrey one Doctor Who convention in
Los Angeles and Christopher Eccleston
was there it was his first time going to
a doctor who dedicated Doctor Who
specific convention and he he was pretty
open about having been a little bit
nervous going but that he felt
wonderfully welcome there I got to meet
him briefly but I got to get my picture
with him I got his autograph he seemed
really thrilled about the reception that
he got there got the entire the entire
crowd and the biggest hall all sang
happy birthday to him on that Sunday
morning cuz it was his birthday last day
of the con and he seemed really
delighted really genuinely so and I
think he has been warming up to coming
back to some extent in Doctor Who now we
still don't have all the details in the
world about his leaving and his very
extended absence the fact that he didn't
come back for things like the fiftieth
anniversary and I've done videos talking
about that before but if there are
issues for him on a personal level about
coming back and playing the part in
front of the camera a lot of that gets
us waged if he gets to do it in audio
that means he's not having to physically
embody the role he's not having to be on
a set that maybe reminds him of the time
that he didn't particularly like he gets
to just be the character in front of a
microphone which I think he'd be more
than capable of doing
I think it's distinctly possible that
we're gonna get that and I'm crossing my
fingers that we will get to hear
Christopher Eccleston as the Ninth
Doctor debuting in the Time Lord
victorious whatever it is and we'll get
to a little bit of speculation on that
not a ton but they and that will then
become the start of Ninth Doctor stories
and Big Finish how amazing
that'd be so one last thing before I
throw out any ideas about what I think
this is gonna involve as far as any
possible stories go what this is not and
you don't need to have inside
information because I don't to realize
this you just have to think it through
this is not an attempt to renegotiate
fans in the wake of series 12 series 12
did not have great ratings however you
feel about it as a series that's a fact
the reasons why it didn't have great
ratings those are also up for debate but
the fact that the ratings were not great
that is a fact no doubt BBC and anyone
who has a stake in the Doctor Who
license would like to buoy things a bit
however there is no way that this is an
apology or an attempt to course-correct
or fix or do anything in any way related
to series 12 how do I know that well
they couldn't announce the various
companies and people involved in this if
contracts weren't already signed and
they couldn't have contracts signed
unless everything had been negotiated
scheduled had been worked out licenses
have been agreed upon series 12 ended in
February I think February early March it
it ended just a cook just a couple of
months ago the amount of time involved
to get everybody on board and to get
everything set up and signed off and
agreed to and especially with the actors
involved because let's just for the
moment like even if Christopher
Eccleston doesn't come back David
Tennant some Big Finish Billy Piper's
Doug Big Finish Paul McGann's done Big
Finish and they'd mentioned Big Finish
so some of these people are coming in to
do audio they have to be available their
schedules have to be clear that has to
be worked out that has being negotiated
that does not get
thrown together in a couple of months in
a panic because a lot of people were
annoyed at the timeless children that
did not happen there is no possible way
because this would have had to have been
conceived organized agreed to agreed on
scheduled and signed off on before they
could make this announcement so I don't
want to hear that not my comments and
not anywhere else so what do I think is
actually gonna happen with this well
obviously the Time Lord victorious is a
very specific callback to the waters of
Mars and David Tennant overstepping the
dr. messing with time to a degree that
he knows he shouldn't so that's an
obvious callback you look at the image
that was put out and we have the Tenth
Doctor in Time Lord robes looking a
little Rassilon one has to wonder if
this is ultimately gonna be some sort of
either all alternate or at the end of
whatever it is it will be in some way
undone and reversed time bubble sort of
thing
normally that sort of thing annoys me
because it's like you know have the
gumption to do it in Cannon and have and
let the effects play out but given that
it's not happening on the show it needs
to happen in some way in a vacuum
because the show is unlikely ever to
acknowledge directly whatever it is so
it can't completely upend in a lasting
way these characters or what we
understand about their history and how
things happened with them so certainly
the name and the look implies David
Tennant went off the deep end and tried
to just wrench control of time itself
which obviously never happened but if it
did and somehow ultimately got resolved
by having to undo and erase all of that
I'd be ok with that in distances I'm not
ok would like the
show doing something like that because
then you just didn't have the guts to
stick by your story line when it's got
to be something that cannot impact Canon
in the same way like Big Finish comics
novels whatever I'm Way more accepting
of something being much more closed off
and complete and not not having
long-term impacts like that I would be
okay with that
so my immediate gut instinct is Tennant
the Tenth Doctor overstepped went off
the deep and possibly even coming out
immediately after the waters of Mars
thinking well that didn't work I'll try
again and still messing with time to the
point that the 8th doctor the Ninth
Doctor and Rose have to somehow stop him
or fix him or correct it or whatever it
is that's my gut instinct I do have to
wonder if to a certain extent it's
almost too obvious because between that
title and David Tennant the Tenth Doctor
looking the way he does in the and the
image if that's just way too obvious and
big finish's gotten pretty good about
throwing curveballs these days okay I
keep citing Big Finish because I have to
assume that they are gonna be the
backbone of this because more than any
way more than the comics way more than
the novels Big Finish is basically
considered by most fans the second
highest tier of Canon behind the show
there's the show there's Big Finish
novels comics maybe they're even at the
same level then like anything else
video games theater experience escape
rooms etc and that also means that I
expect things like what they mentioned
games escape rooms theaters that's gonna
be very sort of off to the side like
you're it's not gonna be a case of it
won't make sense unless you also
experience that it's not gonna be that
for my money the core of it whatever it
is will be a big finished box set and
there will be novels possibly
detailing additional characters points
of view comics fleshing out certain side
characters or maybe a prequel and a an
epilogue comic kind of thing and
whatever the theater and escape room are
just gotta be fun in that setting like
bits of that story thing but they're not
gonna be massively important but
whatever it is I'm gonna be keeping an
eye on III on it we're gonna supposedly
be getting more announcements in the
lead-up September that's when this is
supposed to come out which timing wise
makes a pretty decent amount of sense
you know it's it's it's after the it's
after the summer it's in the fall when a
lot of new shows start up Doctor Who
itself won't be starting up again until
we get the next special which is gonna
be either at the end of the year or the
start of next year I don't know if
they've said whether it's a Christmas
special or another New Year's but anyway
it would be a really good sort of way to
start gearing people up for more Doctor
Who again I this sounds really
intriguing it sounds really cool and I
cannot wait to find out what it is Time
Lord victorious what do you think it's
gonna be whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it all the stuff like
subscribe share this around check out my
patreon buy my book etc etc etc or don't
don't sweat it if you don't want to cuz
end of the day you're the council I just
run the meetings and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]